fait remonter l'info comme quoi ne plus
utiliser les autistes comme insultes
parce que françois fillon un moment il a
utilisé lotissement disant oh des poids
des autistes alors s'il vous plaît un
conte a fait d'avoir eu ce grand débat
donc j'ai parlé d' autisme mais pour moi
aussi ça m'a permis de me dire enfin ça
fait quelques mois que je dis je suis je
ne m'autorisais pas à le dire avant on
n'a pas arrêté de me féliciter de passer
à la télé j'ai trouvé ça très bizarre
parce que c'est par l'important ce n'est
pas de passer à la télé et l'important
justement celle stc la rencontre qu'on
peut avoir en fait à ce moment là de
prendre ce qui a été fait pour essayer
de continuer le travail en fait de se
dire de continuer ça je me présente je
m'appelle clément alias malgré mon
handicap qui est la dyslexie le regard
des autres les différents j'avance de la
vie et on me donnant des objectifs et à
me forger un mental
dépassé par la télé plusieurs fois et et
pouvoir faire comme elle d'appels vidéo
yacht ça m'a permis de pouvoir par être
bon a piqué qui sont trop de stress
maintenant du coup maintenant je suis en
formation de moniteur éducateur et j'ai
déménagé aux nouvelles aquitaine
justement donc j'ai vraiment pu elles
vivent en autonomie en fait également eu
pas mal de personnes qui m'ont contacté
pour me féliciter pour me demander des
conseils mes petites astuces comment
j'arrive à combattre la distinction en
fait
[Applaudissements]